Yeah, tripled checked.
3, 2, 1
Niko: Wren was like
"Just shoot it at me, it'll be fine!"
I'm like you don't want me to do that.
"Come on. Just do it!"
So,
let's pretend that skull is Wren's head and let's see
what would have happened had I not talked him out of this.
There we go.
So the rig works, it's functional.
After the success of GoPro on an arrow,
I want to do a follow up video because,
I really want to do a video where we actually do the perspective of an arrow
shot over a battle.
The GoPro in an arrow it just,
it doesn't shoot far enough for us to actually get that effect of an arrow
like arcing over a battlefield.
Come along with us
as we put a gopro in a cannon.
So this is the Master blaster.
This is an air Cannon that we've built,
so we used to actually shoot gasoline out of it making giant fireballs.
So here's what I'm thinking,
it's just big enough to fit in here.
The very first thing I do is I have to develop a projectile for this.
Now Sam had some ideas.
Let's go see what he's up to,
he's modeling something in 3d for 3D printing.
Sam: So we're gonna basically create a custom 3D printed housing for the GoPro to fit inside of there.
This is a seven-hour print.
Niko: Wow so cool.
Sam: All those little things here are the supports,
we're gonna cut them off to reveal the full form underneath it.
I'm hoping it works
because, probability is not in my favor.
Wren: I would have designed it very differently (laughs nervously).
Anytime you have a sharp corner,
that's what's called a stress concentration.
If you ever have a failure, it's gonna happen exactly where
like a 90 degree sharp corner is.
I actually predict that it will break upon impact.
Sam: Fits very snugly in there.
Niko: Wow.
Sam: All right, someone go down there, and like throw it.
Wren: I honestly don't think this tale is gonna do anything for aerodynamics.
Sam: Having this on here,
does help it.
If you're just throwing a gopro and hoping that the GoPro stays perfectly facing you, yeah.
Sam: Niko has no hands.
Wren: And it's broken.
Sam: And it's broken, here we go.
Wren: Oh hey, it broken in the exact spot I thought it would.
Sam: Right angles.
Man you really put a lot of effort into catching it though (sarcastically).
Wren: The general idea is actually pretty solid.
If we were to do this differently, instead of just like a hard joint
we have like
sort of like a hourglass shape going down and then going back out,
so it's just one smooth line to the end of the tail here.
Sam: I mean honestly turn up pretty well.
Niko: I ah, think it's gonna work pretty well actually.
Wren: Oh my God.
I have no idea if this is actually gonna work though once it flies out of a cannon.
Sam: When you put anything in that cannon it flies out,
literally it doesn't matter what you put in there.
Wren: So snug!
That's not gonna come out, but hey it fits.
Whow!
Sam: Drilled dress lightly bigger hole so that like...
Niko: Man, you guys are the worst.
(Air Horn to Wren!)
Wren: Dude! That was so loud!
(Air Horn to all!)
Wren: Ahh! That's worst than like babys dying.
Guys, I'm really excited for this.
Cmike: mm-hmm.
I'm like really excited for this.
Sam: Right now no one has any idea how far it's gonna go.
Two options,
one aim real high and hope that it doesn't go far, or two aim low
assuming it could go any distance.
Wren: Well, you want to shoot at a 45 degree angle to get the maximum range.
Sam: These things can go incredibly far though,
we'll see we'll see [Niko: well].
Sam: There's no other way to find out than to try
Wren: Let's do this.
I'm nervous man.
Sam: Don't be nervous be excited!
Niko: Here we go,
three, two, one.
(Blown Away!)
Niko: Still rolling,
it survived.
Wren: Oh man. Haha.
Wren: Dude!
Sam: That went way further than I thought it was going to do.
Niko: The thing was like a frickin missile.
Oh, I can't we do a straight up shot.
[Oh!]
Sam: Dude.
Niko: All right I'm gonna shoot this straight up, well...
slightly forward so it won't hit us.
Wren: Here lets, lets,
Wren: let's put this in there before you fill it up, no?
Niko: Three, two, one.
Wren: Crap I don't even know where it went. Oh, I see it.
Niko: Oh baby. Oh, baby. That went so high!
Wren: Unfortunate news
Sam: What?
Wren: We killed the GoPro
Wren & Niko: Noooo!
Niko: Cuts off halfway through. Cut off halfway through.
Wren: So even though we broke the GoPro, we have another and we're gonna go back out tomorrow to fire that one,
but in the mean time it gave me a great opportunity
To do the MATH.
and we knew from Google maps that, that first arrow went
440 feet across the field.
And from looking at the footage
we knew was in the air for exactly 4.3 seconds.
So this thing here left that cannon at 84 miles an hour to fly 440 feet.
For the second shot, the one that actually killed the GoPro,
it was in the air for 7.8 seconds which means
that it went up straight up about
240 to 250 feet.
If you drop a gopro from about 250 feet up it will die.
Let's do it again.
Man. I'm so bummed. I forgot the One Wheel today.
It's perfect for this.
Niko: We do one more ark across the field shot, we're gonna go over the trees.
Hopefully that'll look really cool.
[Right in here.]
Wren: Yep.
Niko: Three, two, one.
Greg: I didn't even see it.
Wren: Hang on, I think I saw it.
Niko: Thought you didn't see anything.
Oh, it's got alot of dirt on the front. Smacked into a dirt mound.
Still rolling though.
Wren: Alright.
Niko: Sweet.
So far so good.
The GoPro is still rolling when I picked it up.
so now we can do the most dangerous shot of them all,
the straight-up shot
Wren brought a Baseball glove,
he's going to try to catch it and keep it from breaking.
I hope it works.
Wren: Me too.
Niko: Wren don't let my baby died.
Wren: I will do my best, but I make no promises.
Greg: Good luck Wren.
Niko: Three, two, one.
Wren: Its buried!
Just completely. Here lets see if its...
Still rolling.
(Cheering)
Niko: Oh, man this is what it looks like the fall.
It's that quick, lights out?
Last shot.
Wren: Instead of doing like some crazy distance test.
I want you to fire it directly at me.
Niko: So you want me to shoot a cannon at you?
Wren: Yes.
Niko: With a large heavy projectile that's a giant dart.
Wren: Yes
Niko: Okay, let's do it.
Niko: Further back
Wren: No, heres good!
Niko: Trust me
Wren: Trust me!
Niko: Ready?
Wren: Yeah.
Niko: 3, 2, 1.
I told you to go further back.
Wren: Your ark was too high.
Wren: That went way over my head.
Niko: Wren your blatant disregard for the safety of my camera. Ah!
So now we're gonna go back to the studio and we are going to add counter rotation to all the shots.
Wren: Do you guys want to see it stabilized?
Niko: Yes.
Wren: Alright, ready?
(Knowledgeable Screaming!)
So this is the GoPro that we shot out on Monday,
And it doesn't work anymore.
It still turns on but it doesn't really work, so we don't have any need for it.
So we thought it actually might be fun to do a little bit of a giveaway here.
So if you leave a comment below telling us what you want us to put a GoPro on next,
we will pick one person at random and we will send them this GoPro.
So leave a comment. Tell us what you want to see.
Do you want the broken GoPro?
We'll sign it, we'll make it extra cool. Will sign it.
Yeah, we got some silver sharpies.
Yeah, so thanks for watching guys.
If you're not subscribed consider subscribing. It's really cool. We make a lot of good stuff, whoo.